There are an estimated 30 million human slaves
in the world today, more than ever before
in history.
The country with the most slaves is India.
Welcome to RIF.
All of Australia's snakes, spiders, sharks,
crocodiles and poisonous sea creatures combined
only kill 5 people per year.
Whereas horseback riding accidents kill 20
Australians per year.
There is a company that provides private flights
for individuals who want to join the "mile
high club".
For tidy sum of $425.00 you get a 1 hour flight,
chocolates, champagne, and a curtain.
Two surgeons once used a coat hanger, brandy,
and a tube to operate on a collapsed lung
during an aeroplane flight, and they succeeded.
A bat that dies while roosting will continue
to hang upside until something shakes it loose.
Only one half of a dolphin's brain goes to
sleep at a time.
This allows dolphins to sleep under water
without drowning.
Studies show that if people adjust their facial
expression to reflect an emotion, they actually
begin to feel that emotion.
Male lobster's bladders are in their heads,
and when they fight, they squirt each other
in the face with urine.
The strongest muscle in the human body is
the tongue.
It can lift up to 80 times its own weight.
Americans make up 5% of the world's population,
yet they produce 35% of the world's waste.
A water molecule will spend 9 days in the
atmosphere, 2 weeks in a river, 10 years in
a large lake, and between 3,000 to 5,000 years
in an ocean.